♪ ♪
>> Laura: BEFORE THE BREAK WE
DETAILED MUCH OF THE DEEP STATES
DISLIKE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND OVER THE WEEKEND, FORMER CIA
DIRECTOR JOHN BRENNAN DIRECTED
THIS REVEALING TWEET OF THE
PRESIDENT.
WHEN THE FULL EXTENT OF YOUR
BANALITY, MORAL TURPITUDE AND
POLITICAL CORRUPTION BECOMES
KNOWN, YOU WILL TAKE YOUR
RIGHTFUL PLACE AS A DISGRACE
DEMAGOGUE IN THE DUSTBIN OF
HISTORY.
YOU MAY SCAPEGOAT AND HE
McCABE BUT YOU WILL NOT
DESTROY AMERICA.
AMERICA WILL TRIUMPH OVER YOU.
WHAT BAD WRITING.
IS THE FBI COLLUDING WITH THE
INTEL COMMUNITY TO DESTROY THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY?
LET'S PUT THAT TO THE TEST.
CHRIS IS WITH US AND RETIRED FBI
SPECIAL AGENT TERRY LANE AND
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR AND
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" REPORTER
BYRON YORK.
SO MUCH TO GET THERE.
WITH GOT TO BE PITHY ABOUT THIS.
I WANT TO PLAY FOR YOU RIGHT OFF
THE BAT, THIS COMMENTARY, THE
TESTIMONY BY BRENNAN ON MAY 23RD
OF LAST YEAR AT THE HOUSE UNTIL
COMMITTEE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> HAVE YOU EVER REQUESTED THAT
A U.S. PERSONS NAME BE UNMASKED?
>> YES I HAVE.
>> ARE YOU AWARE OF ANY REQUEST
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY THAT WERE
DENIED?
>> I DIDN'T HAVE VISIBILITY INTO
ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT, SO I
DON'T RECALL ONE THAT I WAS
DENIED.
>> Laura: BASICALLY IF YOU ASK
FOR SOMEONE TO BE UNMASKED IT'S
GOING TO GET UNMASKED.
HE KIND OF SAYS I DO NOT -- I
DON'T KNOW THE WHOLE RANGE --
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT IN
LIGHT OF WHAT WE KNOW NOW, HIS
TWEETS, THE FOCUS ON GETTING
TRUMP.
HE IS A DEMAGOGUE.
THAT'S A FORMER FBI DIRECTOR.
CIA DIRECTOR, EXCUSE ME.
>> CLEARLY HE WAS STILL WORKING
FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA WHILE HE WAS
WORKING FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN SO MUCH
POLITICIZATION AT THE TOPS OF
THESE TWO AGENCIES, THE FBI AND
THE CIA.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I HATE TO
CONCEDE, I HATE TO ADMIT, BUT
UNDER DIRECTOR COMEY, CLEARLY
THERE WAS AN AGENDA TO KILL THE
CLINTON EMAIL INVESTIGATION AND
NOT EVEN LET THE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE -- WHERE THE FOUNDATION
INVESTIGATION CONTINUE OR BE
CONDUCTED IN A WAY THAT IS
DESIGNED TO GET TO THE TRUTH OF
THE MATTER.
IF GOT TWO THINGS GOING ON
THERE.
I ALSO THINK, HOWEVER, LAURA,
THAT THE SPECIAL COUNSEL NEEDS
TO EXIST AND WE NEED TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF SOME OTHER THINGS
AS WELL.
>> Laura: FIRING, JOHN
BRENNAN, I THINK, SHOWED IN HIS
TWEET THIS WEEKEND JUST HOW MUCH
ANIMOSITY HAS BUILT UP, LIKE
CHUCK SCHUMER WARNED, AGAINST
THE PRESIDENT.
SAMANTHA POWERS ALSO HAS A
RESPONSE.
NOT A GOOD IDEA TO PISS OFF JOHN
BRENNAN, THAT SOME LOVELY
LANGUAGE COMING FROM SAMANTHA
POWERS.
>> IT'S AN INCREDIBLE
UNDERSTATEMENT.
GO BACK TO THE TRANSITION.
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN ELECTED.
INTELLIGENCE CHIEFS ARE WORKING
ON THE REPORTS ABOUT RUSSIAN
MEDDLING.
THEY FINISH IT IN JANUARY OF
2017.
THEY BRIEFED PRESIDENT OBAMA ON
IT AND THEY ALSO BRIEFED
PRESIDENT OBAMA ABOUT THE
DOSSIER AND THE SALACIOUS
DETAILS IN THE DOSSIER.
THE NEXT DAY, JANUARY 6TH THEY
GO UP TO TRUMP TOWER.
FOUR OF THEM ARE IN THERE,
INCLUDING JOHN BRENNAN AND JAMES
COMEY AND I TALKED TO HIM ABOUT
THE REPORT ON RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE, AND THEN BY
PREARRANGEMENT, THREE OF THEM
LEAVE, LEAVING COMEY ALONE WITH
THE PRESIDENT-ELECT, WHO TELLS
THEM ABOUT THE DOSSIER.
>> Laura: BUT COMEY KNOWS THE
DOSSIER IS PAID FOR, DOES HE
NOT, AT THAT POINT, BY
FUSION GPS.
FUSION GPS GETS PAID FOR BY...
>> BY THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: RIGHT.
DOES HE TELL THE PRESIDENT THAT?
>> NOT TO OUR KNOWLEDGE.
THINK OF THIS FROM THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT'S POINT OF VIEW.
FIRST FACE-TO-FACE MEETING WITH
THE FBI AND THEY TOLD HIM, BY
THE WAY, WE KNOW ABOUT YOU AND
THOSE HOOKERS IN MOSCOW.
THAT'S GETTING OFF ON A REALLY
BAD FOOT.
>> Laura: MENTIONING TO THE
PRESIDENT WE ARE ONTO YOU.
>> HOW ELSE COULD HE THINK THAT?
>> Laura: JOKE WAS ON RADIO
TODAY WITH ME
, TERRY, AND HE'S COMING IN AS A
NEW LAWYER OF THE CRIME TEAM.
A LONGTIME CONTRIBUTOR TO THE
SHOW AND OTHERS ON FOX, AND THIS
IS WHAT HE SAID, LET'S LISTEN.
>> I REALLY BELIEVE THAT BRENNAN
AND CLAPPER WITH THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE MOST, MOST RESPONSIBLE FOR
ALL OF THE VIOLATIONS OF LAW
THAT HAVE OCCURRED DURING THE
2016 CAMPAIGN THAT INVOLVED NOT
ONLY THE UNMASKING, BUT THE
ILLEGAL DISCLOSURES AND OTHER
THINGS.
SO IN MANY WAYS THIS TWEET BY
BRENNAN WAS A BLESSING IN
DISGUISE.
>> Laura: FOR THAT HE'S BEING
CALLED, AGAIN, A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST.
DONALD TRUMP HIRING A CONSPIRACY
THEORIST FOR ONE OF HIS -- ON
HIS LEGAL TEAM AND SO FORTH.
YOUR REACTION?
>> I WILL TELL YOU LIKE WE SAY
IN TEXAS.
BRENNAN IS AN IDIOT.
HE HAS NO IDEA HOW THE FBI
OPERATES.
HIS AGENCY OPERATES COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT.
ALTHOUGH THEY TAKE AN OATH TO
THE CONSTITUTION, THEY DON'T
FOLLOW THE CONSTITUTION AS WE
HAVE TO.
THE FBI HAS TO FOLLOW THE
CONSTITUTION TO THE LETTER.
WHENEVER WE PROSECUTE SOMEBODY,
WHENEVER WE INVESTIGATE SOMEONE,
WE HAVE TO FOLLOW ALL THE RULES
OF EVIDENCE, ALL THE CRIMINAL
PROCEDURES.
CIA DOESN'T DO THAT, SO I'M NOT
SURPRISED THAT BRENNAN COMES UP
WITH THIS IDIOTIC STATEMENT THAT
HE MAKES, BECAUSE, AGAIN, HE CAN
OPERATE ON CONJECTURE.
HIS AGENCY DOESN'T HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE TRUTH.
THEY THEIR STOCK AND TRADE IS
ACTUALLY THE UNTRUTHS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A DEEP
STATE, BUT IF THERE IS AN
ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN BRENNAN IS
PART OF THAT DEEP STATE.
>> Laura: CHRIS I WANT TO GO
BACK TO YOU BECAUSE YOU WROTE A
PIECE FOR FOX NEWS ABOUT HOW
TRUTH TELLING BY THE FBI, GOING
BACK TO McCABE'S FIRING HERE,
IN A GENERAL SENSE OF
LAWLESSNESS, CONFLICT OF
INTEREST, UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR,
THE TELLING OF THE TRUTH IS SO
CRITICAL FOR THE FBI.
THAT'S A RULE THAT MUST BE
FOLLOWED AND IF IT'S NOT, IT
BREAKS ON THE TRUST.
TELUS.
>> CERTAINLY FIDELITY, BRAVERY,
INTEGRITY IS THE FBI'S MOTTO.
ITS INTEGRITY BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO TESTIFY ABOUT THINGS THAT
THEY DO.
THEY HAVE PEOPLE'S LIFE, LIBERTY
AND PROPERTY IN THEIR HAND.
THEY CAN PUT THEIR THUMB ON THE
SCALE OF AN INVESTIGATION AND
DEPRIVE SOMEONE OF LIBERTY IN A
SECOND.
THEY HAVE TO TELL THE TRUTH AND
THEY CAN'T NUANCE THE TRUTH AND
THEY CAN'T SPIN IT.
THEY HAVE TO TELL THE WHOLE
STORY THE WAY IT COMES OUT
FACTUALLY.
ANDY McCABE KNEW THAT.
HIS OWN OPR -- OPR REPORTED
DIRECTLY TO THEM.
THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR OF THE
OPR WAS ONE OF HIS DIRECT
REPORTERS.
SHE BASICALLY FIRED HER OWN BOSS
BECAUSE THE FBI WAS CLEANING ITS
OWN HOUSE.
>> Laura: BYRON, I WANT TO GO
BACK TO YOU.
MICHAEL, A LAWYER FOR McCABE,
TWEETED OUT WE WILL NOT BE
RESPONDING -- THE WHOLE TRUTH
WILL COME OUT IN DUE COURSE.
THE TWEETS CONFIRMED THAT HE HAS
CORRUPTED THE ENTIRE PROCESS
THAT LED TO MR. MCCABE'S
TERMINATION HAS RENDERED IT
ILLEGITIMATE.
WHAT CAN WE EXPECT?
>> I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
PEOPLE WHO KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT
THIS CASE, AND EVEN ADAM SCHIFF,
THE DEMOCRAT ON HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE WHO NEVER MISSES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CRITICIZE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WHO SAYS
PERHAPS THIS FIRING WAS PROPER,
AND THEN HE CRITICIZED THE WAY
IN WHICH IT WAS DONE.
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THIS ARE BEING
CAREFUL NOT TO DENOUNCE THIS AS
AN ILLEGITIMATE SORT OF ACT.
WE DO KNOW THAT THE NONPARTISAN
PARTS OF THE FBI, OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL WERE
BEHIND THIS.
AT LAST, McCABE HAD A MEDIA
TOUR READY BEFORE THIS.
HE HAD DONE SEVERAL INTERVIEWS
WITH MEDIA PEOPLE AND THE ONE
THING HE DID NOT TALK ABOUT WITH
THE DETAILS OF WHAT LED TO HIS
FIRING.
>> Laura: INTERESTING.
INTERESTING.